[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصين
تدير مجموعه الضغط عبر البحار مجموعه
مؤثره جدا تحاول ان تقلل الخساره
التكنولوجيه من ونحن او هي تقول بان الغير
بسميه هم عنصريه تجاههم ولكن في الحقيقه
اكبر جنوبيه واليابان وكنها دول اسيويه
هاي من اكبر المنتقدين
النشاطات الصينيه غير الاخلاقيه والذين
فصل كامل بهذا الخصوص حول شكاوى الجنوبيه
واليابان
النشاطات الطابور الخامس هذه يجب ان تعالج
ولكن يجب ان تعالج من دون التضحيه بالقيم
الليبراليه هذه مساله هامه هنالك حركه
نشطه في الدوار الاكاديميه في الولايات
المتحده واوروبا ايضا ونسميها
بمبادره الامن الابحاث والتي تعمل على هذا
المجال المساله الثانيه
هي تو علومي او مراقبه علوم المطار
المفتوحه
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تقود فيه الرقاقات
وتصنيع والصين متقدمه في توافر
جدا لخوارزميه التعلم
وكلاء البلدان
قويه ومع تركيز مختلف لكل دوله انا شخصيا
اعتقد بالنبات المتحده وبريطانيا
يركزان اكثر من اللازم على حلول البيانات
الكبرى وفيها فوائد التجاريه قصيره الامد
الى الزملاء في المركز يخالفوني الراي
ولكننا نرى ان جوانب هامه من الموت تحتيه
الخاصه بالابحاث الذكاء الاصطناعي في
الصين
الصناعي التقليدي
لمستقبل لاحد
ويضعون الكثير من الموارد اقصده في الصين
في التكنولوجيا المستوحاه من الدماغ
[موسيقى]